[Applause]
christopher thank you so much for being
here i told you by stage i am a huge fan
of yours
and uh your performance in in glorious
bastards i think ruin has ruined my
marriage because every time that
movie comes on i can't stop watching it
and i'm always watching you i loved your
performances
blue blue what's that blue blue blue
blue
you interrupted me for blue blue
no one gets away with that but you
christophe
quiet blue blue
thank you for being here though very
excited you know what i love me about i
love about love me i
slept there i can't speak tonight
because of the google uh
you are such an amazing actor you're so
intense uh in that movie you can be so
in glorious bastards you're so charming
and then suddenly this dead-eyed stare
that you can give that i find so
chilling that you're giving me right now
yeah you're so good at that uh i know
that you are
there are uh you're from austria is that
that's right
and uh there are like many americans
unfortunately i don't know enough about
the rest of the world and i'm familiar
with familiar with germany but i don't
know the
the difference say in the culture
between say austrians and germans can
you enlighten us oh the difference
between
austrians and germans is like the
difference between a
uh a battleship and uh
a waltz a battleship and a waltz
that's about the difference between
really yeah so there's really not a lot
of similarities is what you're saying
how are the austrians different i mean i
know there's the the germans there's the
cliche which is they have no sense of
humor do they that's not a cliche
it's just 100 percent true well it's
it's
it's sort of you know um germans i
i hope i'm not hurting anybody's
feelings again
but james does go out on television yeah
i mean the germans might hear about this
well you know they won't they won't hear
about this please speak freely it's just
thank you
it's just it's just us in a fake movie
please speak thank you
i think germans always go for for a
head-on collision
you know and and it's it's never it's it
doesn't
it rarely has sort of grace and melody
and rhythm it's just
and uh i know irony there's no sense of
they just say exactly what they mean
exactly everything else is is dubious
and slimy and
they're suspicious of yeah yeah i'm
highly dubious and slimy so yeah
i love it when a guest just comes out
and says that uh but you uh austrians
then have
a sense of humor they're well it's it's
austrians tend to make their lives
easier so first of all they are very
polite
and second they don't mean it so
and and it's just you know a mode of
communication
and exchange and in between you have a
sip so
um you know what can go wrong very nice
well i'm irish i understand
yeah exactly well the same way we are
very nice but we don't mean it no
absolutely but but but you know ireland
has nine
literature nobel prize winners nine yeah
i mean that says something
for communication in a culture yes
and um and um that the difference
between
in all seriousness if that's appropriate
at all no
we'll cut this part out um
the difference between austrians and
germans is very much like english and
irish
right very much right there's the
there's there's more of the sense of the
silly and the absurd